moi aussi
moi aussi je suis très heureux qu'on se
retrouve en effet comme j me l'a dit
en principe il devrait y avoir erwan
balanant à ma place sur cette scène mais
sa circonscription est tellement éloigné
de guidel
150 mètres que
qu' il n'a pas réussi à se libérer à
temps mais je vous promets que vous
l'entendrez
je suis très très heureux pour des
raisons que vous savez
ces raisons sont la gravité des temps
l'importance des décisions que nous
devons prendre le climat que nous devons
porter
la la manière d'être qui doit
être la nôtre celle de notre famille
politique comme on dit de notre courant
politique
dans ce moment historique
en effet comme jimmy l'a dit
on a pris la décision alors que ce
n'était pas du tout évident
parce que à l'épaule que les précaution
l'emportaient sur l'audace
mais il nous a semblé tout ensemble dans
notre exécutif avec tous nos
responsables avec marc fesneau avec
patrick mignola
avec
jean-noël barrot avec
les ministres au féminin et au masculin
qui vont nous rejoindre tout au cours de
ces journées
avec fabien il nous a semblé que c'était
le moment de manifester
à la fois optimisme et volonté
que notre pays était tout entier
pris part ce que le coc vide a
représenté
pour tous et en particulier pour les
plus fragiles qu'il y avait dans notre
pays une très grande
inquiétude
sur cette question de savoir si nous
allions pouvoir retrouver les liens les
contacts les regards
les rencontres qui sont celles qui font
notre vie et nous a semblé que c'était
pour une
communauté comme la nôtre le moment de
marquer que nous voulions être de ce
côté de ce côté de la renaissance ce
côté de de la volonté de vivre de ce
côté delà de la volonté de refaire
ensemble
une société civique mais une société où
on peut à nouveau rencontrer l'autre et
que c'était un geste au moment où tant
de gens s'interrogeaient sur la
vaccination sur le pass sanitaire que
nos députés ils sont nombreux ici
examiner et nous a semblé que c'était le
moment de rencontre et ici aussi les
élus locaux nombreux alors je félicite
les morbihannais que vous êtes je veux
saluer le maire de lorient fabrice loher
qui est là au premier rang et que vous
trouvez
ap le livre
nous a semblé que c'était oman et je
crois qu'on a très bien fait
et
probablement parce que les enjeux
apparaissent aujourd'hui
plus lourd
plus exigeant
qu'on ne pouvait le deviner il ya encore
quelques mois
on vit dans la société française au
moment où la démocratie est
chahuté
et même assez souvent bouleversé
par des prises de positions qui sont
toujours plus tranchée toujours plus
agressive
toujours plus violente
est à bien des égards inquiétante
et nous nous avons une responsabilité
particulière
et même si j'ose dire nous avons deux
responsabilités la première de ses
responsabilités c'est une responsabilité
historique parce que nous avons
contribué puissamment avec nos alliés de
en marche nous avons contribué
puissamment à l'élection du président de
la république
et le rôle qu emmanuel macron joue
aujourd'hui
si j'ose dire là la prestance de
président de la république et la sienne
le soin qu'il prend de dalé profondément
au coeur des problèmes qui se posent
pour la france pour l'europe et pour le
monde
au milieu des crises sans nombre que
nous partageons
cette responsabilité d'avoir participé à
son élection elle s'accompagne aussi de
cette responsabilité ne vous trompez pas
assez rare dans l'histoire
d'avoir été des acteurs patrick
mignola président du groupe et les
sénateurs qui sont là d'avoir été des
acteurs
engagés
constant
loyaux ça va sans dire et
imaginatif
de la majorité exigeant parce que nous
croyons que la démocratie parlementaire
c'est important dans un pays comme le
nôtre et c'est important dans une époque
comme celle que nous vivons on aura
l'occasion d'en parler beaucoup
mais exigeant et inventif
et en quatre ans et demi vous pouvez
regarder les annales en quatre ans et
demi ce n'est pas souvent que des
majorités peuvent vivre sans crise
profonde
sans contestation interne sans complot
des uns contre les autres sans fronde
des périodes aussi agitée que celle que
nous avons vécue personnes moment où
emmanuel macron a été élu n'aurait songé
à la gravité et à la fréquence des
crises que nous avons traversée et donc
ça nous donne une responsabilité
particulière il ya une deuxième
responsabilité c'est que les temps qui
s'ouvre un
sondé tant
de défis
les temps qui s'ouvre sont si agitée
cependant que sarah l aïr y entrent dans
la salle
et que erwan balanant la campagne
[Musique]
il te rends compte que je suis désolé
roanne on a fait tout ce qu'on pouvait
pour d'attendre mais on a on a
tenu compte de la distance qui entre ta
circonscription et guidel pour excuser
30 ans d'absence
oui ben je n'en doute pas
et nous aussi et donc
les temps sont tellement
exigeant il présente des défis tellement
considérables que nous avons le devoir
si je pouvais souligné ce mot trois fois
je soulignerai nous avons le devoir de
nous interroger sur
notre action
nos organisations
la forme qu'elles doivent prendre pour
être à la hauteur des défis de ces
années qui viennent
cette interrogation comme vous le savez
nous tous ensemble les responsables du
mouvement ont pensé qu'il était juste
de transformer cette interrogation
propositions et cette proposition c'est
celle de construire le pôle central de
la vie politique française pour les
années et je crois les décennies qui
viennent
alors je veux m'arrêter une seconde sur
cette idée
je ne crois pas toi parti politique ça
soit fait pour une élection
je ne crois même pas qu'un parti
politique soit fait pour une personne
je crois qu'un parti politique c'est une
pluie un puissant courant philosophique
politique
doctrinal on dit doctrinal chez nous
parce qu'on n'aime pas le mot
idéologique qui apparaît trop
systématique mais tout ça c'est la même
chose une vision du monde qui ne
ressemble à aucune autre
en même temps un courant politique 7
une implantation locale des raisons de
d'actifs d'acteurs de sympathisants
d'élus et ça joue naturellement un rôle
très important troisièmement une
formation politique c'est
peguy disait une amie qui est une cité
qu'est ce que ça veut dire une amitié
une cité ça veut dire qu'il y as entre
nous des liens qui dépasse de beaucoup
l'intérêt électoral la recherche de
mandat le l'avantagent qu'on peut tirer
de telle ou telle situation
il ya entre nous des liens que l'on
appelait
en latin affectio societatis
nous aimons être ensemble nous
connaissons pour beaucoup d'entre nous
depuis des années nous avons éprouvé
ce que sont les difficultés ensemble
nous avons traversé
les épreuves et peut-être même les
déserts
sans jamais nous laisser décourager
et ça au moins une vertu c'est que ça
forge une solidarité
ça forge
cette chaîne qui nous soude
et enfin une organisation politique ce
sont des leaders des responsables qui
ensemble assume devant l'opinion
publique
les prises de position et le destin
d'une famille politique mais nous avons
éprouvé nous et pas seulement nous
nos amis et nos alliés aussi le fait que
notre organisation actuelle ne suffisait
pas
on a vécu les municipales et les
régionales
et on a vu tous ensemble que allez je
vais le dire d'une manière
absolument retenue qu'on pouvait faire
mieux
nous avons vu tous ensemble que l'état
actuel de nos organisations du
fonctionnement
de nos ententes ne permettait pas de
lancer le grand mouvement de
persuasion de
conviction de conquête de l'opinion
que nous estimons indispensable
je suis sûr que tous vous avez été
frappé de ça nous connaissons tous des
dizaines de personnes dont nous croyons
nous savons qu'elles partagent
les
la manière de voir le les valeurs comme
on dit qui sont les nôtres est-ce
qu'elle s'engage non s'engage moment de
l'élection présidentielle
mais
ça ne se perpétuent pas dans le temps on
sait très bien nous aussi un moment de
l'élection présidentielle de 2007 on a
fait des dizaines et des dizaines et des
dizaines de milliers d'adhérents en deux
semaines
mais après il faut s'enraciner après il
faut que que le
que la soudure prennent
et c'est de ça j'en suis persuadé dont
nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui
et comme tout le monde a fait la même
expérience
alors je crois que c'est le moment de
faire un pas en avant à une condition
que j'ai exprimés de toutes les manières
je vais le redire sous cette forme cette
condition c'est que personne de ceux qui
vont participer ou qui nous l'espérons
vont participer à l'édification de cette
nouvelle organisation
personne ne perdent rien de ce qu'il est
ni de ce qu'il a parce que c'est tout à
fait légitime que chacun soit fier et la
volonté de défendre
ses choix
et son être profond
nous avons une histoire dieu sait c'est
pas moi qui vais dire le contraire
nous avons une histoire
et cette histoire elle est une partie de
notre scène
c'est ça qui nous constitue
on a tous ensemble vécu et ce qui nous
précédaient ont vécu
quelque chose de tout à fait essentiel
je veux simplement rappeler qu'on va
célébrer dans deux ans le centième
anniversaire
du premier mouvement du courant
politique hockey d'une manière ou d'une
autre nous nous rattachons en tout cas
auquel moi je me rattache
c'était la création en 1924 du parti
démocrate populaire
je regarde jean noël barrot parce qu'on
en parle souvent le parti démocrate
populaire il a une caractéristique
que je tiens à rappeler devant vous
c'est le seul parti qui est dit non aux
accords de munich
d'une manière ou d'une autre
tous les autres partis je mets le parti
communiste
à part d' à cet instant tous les autres
partis ont applaudi aux accords de
munich et ce mouvement le parti
démocrate populaire avait un petit
journal qui s'appelait l'aube
l'éditorialiste de l'aube à une destinée
d'abord glorieuses et après tourmenté
puisque c'était georges bidault c'était
un jeune agrégé d'histoire et géographie
qui était professeur dans un lycée
parisien et
il est l idée réaliste de l'aube et il
finit son éditorial sur les accords de
munich par cette phrase que je ne me
lasserai jamais de citer
lorsqu'il s'agit de dire non
le meilleur moment c'est le premier
[Applaudissements]
est ce que voulait dire cette phrase
dans ce moment historique tellement
particulier
c'est que nous portions un idéal qui ne
pouvait céder devant aucune menace
qui ne pouvait céder devant aucune
épreuve de force lorsque l'essentiel est
en jeu
ce grand courant politique est un
courant politique intransigeant
et le moment que nous vivons les thèmes
qui sont évoqués dans les campagnes
électorales par les intervenants divers
et variés est un moment où il est bon de
savoir
sur quoi on est intransigeant
quels sont les convictions quelles sont
les règles
quels sont les principes sur lesquels
nous ne céderons pas
et ceci
est d'une certaine manière cette
affirmation est d'une certaine manière
un guide pour ce que nous avons à faire
on a besoin de réunir les forces de tous
ceux qui croient la même chose
qui ont les mêmes certitudes en termes
de principes et de valeurs
qui sont à la même hauteur d'idéal
pour qu'il soit plus fort ensemble ayant
expérimenté que diviser leurs forces
étaient insuffisantes
voilà un des thèmes majeurs
de ce que de séjourner que nous allons
vivre
comme vous avez vu cette proposition
dont il faut mettre au point tous les
détails et tous les principes mais cette
proposition a été accueillie avec
intérêt par nos alliés ils vont avoir
l'occasion par nos amis par nos alliés
ils vont avoir l'occasion de
de venir s'exprimer sur ces sujets de
vendre
c'est pas si tout le monde mesure les
risques que nous traversons
on est dans un univers
univers géopolitique je salue les
députés européens
européenne et européens qui sont là
on est dans un moment où
les équilibres de la planète
en termes de puissance
et profondément déstabilisé
on est dans un moment où des événements
planétaires je pense évidemment
à tout ce qui touche à l'environnement à
la préservation de notre patrimoine à la
sauvegarde des équilibres qui sont
aujourd'hui très menacée
tout le monde mesure ce que ce que ça
veut dire le
déséquilibre démographique
sur lesquels j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer comme commissaire au plan
pose des problèmes qui sont devant nous
comme une bombe à retardement
quand vous avez des continents et des
régions de la planète entière
qui vivent à la fois la pauvreté
et l'explosion démographique
et que vous avez d'autres zones opulente
riches
qui elle au contraire
connaissent une dépression démographique
alors ils se passent inéluctablement
où interviennent et luc ta ble ment une
menace
de vases communicants
et depuis que le monde est monde
songez à ce qui s'est passé pour l'
empire romain pour la grèce
depuis que le monde est monde
chaque fois qu'une situation de cet
ordre s'est créé évidemment ça entraîner
des drames
impossible à maîtriser et la disparition
de ceux qui se trouvaient dans la
situation d'être
opulent et débordés
crise immense
la démocratie
qu'on croyait il ya quelques années
encore être le destin commun de
l'humanité être inéluctable devant nous
tous devant nos d'abord bien sûr mais
devant
tous les pays européens et puis après
devant toutes les grandes régions du
monde
qu'on croyait de voir s'établir d'une
certaine manière d'elle-même
la démocratie est aujourd'hui
profondément discuté dans son essence
même
c'est évidemment le le cas de l'immense
empire chinois
qui est lui même devant des questions
intimidante
un milliard trois cent mille personnes
dont les démographes disent qu'elles
pourraient se retrouver à 600 milles
dans quelques décennies à 600 millions
dans quelques décennies
divisée de moitié
et la chine elle-même qui avait adopté
vous savez la politique de l'autoritaire
de l'enfant unique et l'interdiction
d'avoir deux enfants l'interdiction
imposée d'avoir deux enfants
vient de dire deux enfants et même trois
enfants s'il le faut parce que ils
vivent la menace immédiate
sur leur existence et la chine a choisi
un modèle politique qui est pas du tout
celui là qui est le modèle 2
l'imperium
de la maîtrise de la prise de contrôle
des villes individuel
au bénéfice de l'intérêt collectif tel
que défini par le parti
on dit qu'il y aura en chine plus d'une
caméra par habitant d'ici quelques mois
ou quelques années
et peut-être il vous a pas échappé parce
que c'est un cadre pour notre réflexion
aussi vous aura pas échappé que la chine
vient de renouer avec le caractère
révolutionnaire économique et sociale de
son histoire puisque désormais
si on écoute attentivement la la chasse
aux milliardaires est ouverte
hier on disait
cette
l'ultralibéralisme et l'explosion des
richesses matérielles
sous le contrôle du parti aujourd'hui le
contrôle du parti et rester mais le
contrôle des situations sociales est
aussi semble-t-il en cours mince affaire
l'inde en proie à des tensions
identitaires considérable
considérables et qui va dépasser la
chine en terme de population
avec toutes les difficultés que que cela
signale et puis
l'immense continent africain
à nos portes
avec des liens avec nous qu'ils
qu'aucun ne peut nier et qui elle va
connaître cette afrique une explosion
démographique pour l'instant absolument
pas maîtrisé et une explosion parallèle
de la pauvreté
si on ne voit pas ça voit rien
si on ne voit pas que l'alliance
traditionnelle avec les états unis que
les plus atlantistes d'entre nous je
n'en ai jamais été
considérée comme allant de soi
parfaitement naturel que l'amérique
était là pour préserver protéger
garantir nos libertés la suite
ils viennent de découvrir une fois de
plus il fallait une certaine naïveté
historique pour croire le contraire
vient de découvrir une fois de plus que
l'amérique n'hésitait jamais à sacrifier
ses intérêts ses principes à ses
intérêts
et celui qui ne voit pas que ça pose à
l'europe des questions absolument vital
celui-là ne voit rien
est-ce que je puisse simplement remarqué
avec vous que toutes ces questions là
non seulement nous les avons identifiés
nous les avons posées
et nous y avons apporté au moins des
orientations de réponse
pas assez puissante pour quoi il faut
devenir puissants mais on s'est pas
trompé dans ses dans ses orientations là
et on ne s'est pas trompé non plus sur
les crispations interne à la france qui
sont comme chacun d'entre nous de ses
considérables qui vont avoir sur la
campagne électorale et la suite des
conséquences très très importante
qui menacent notre équilibre
avec un travail
assidu pour essayer de répondre mais
bien des réponses qui demeure encore à
formuler dans le dans la manière dont
nous voyons l'avenir du pays
nous sommes à ce rendez vous là
et c'est parce que nous sommes à ce
rendez vous là
nous avons
identifiait combattu l'abstention par
parra charisme de la manière dont est
organisée la démocratie française dont
sont organisées les élections dont été
oublié j'allais dire mépriser le
principe de représentations
auxquelles tout le monde devrait avoir
accès tous les français pourvu que il
représente un nombre d'électeurs
respecter
un million d'électeurs 5% 5 millions
d'électeurs à peu près devraient avoir
accès à la représentation et le
parlement auraient un autre visage
lé débat au parlement prendrait un autre
sens et la fonction gouvernementale
elle-même obligerait
à entendre
a rassemblé
à représenter des courants c'est
absolument comme ça que de gaulle voyait
la vème république
on aura l'occasion de s'en expliquer on
a vu tout ça
on a vu les problèmes de la démocratie
excusez moi de dire que la manière dont
a été écarté la banque de la démocratie
que nous avions
proposée et même imposé
dans le
dans l'élection présidentielle les
législatives de 2010 est
cette institution qui garantissait que
si vous êtes un courant politique
représentatif alors vous n'avez pas à
les supplier les banques privées de vous
prêter de l'argent parce qu'il y a
quelque chose au dessus de l'intérêt des
banques privées c'est l'intérêt général
c'est la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
on ne s'est trompé sur aucun de ces
points alors maintenant il s'agit de se
poser la question des pas en avant que
nous devons faire
et moi je pense que c'est une
responsabilité éminente
que celle d'une famille politique qui
peut contribuer puissamment à construire
une organisation nouvelle
un pôle de référence pour l'ensemble de
la vie politique française
pour les soutiens et pour les opposants
au moment où tout le monde se divise
au moment où d'un bout à l'autre de
l'échiquier on n'a que des compétitions
de
personnes d'ego
d'excès
avec
la scissiparité qui fait que partout
chacun construit son propre son propre
bidule
nous que nous choisissions si nous le
choisissons de rassembler
de réunir
d'unifier dans le respect de chacun
alors je trouve que ça a une
signification qui dépasse de beaucoup
les frontières des partis politiques
[Applaudissements]
décision de responsabilité
dans un moment d'immense gravité
dans un moment d'immense menace
alors c'est un combat décennale
gelé moi même ce n'est avec mes amis
dont beaucoup sont dans cette salle
je considère que on peut aujourd'hui
le porter
jusqu'à la réalité ça soit plus une
intention mais quand doivent le réaliser
ensemble
ce jour là si nous le faisons
si nos amis le valais tout semble
définir un ensemble
si nous le faisons alors je trouve que
nous aurons fait
pour notre pays
quelque chose qui vaut la peine quelque
chose dont on se souviendra c'est
pourquoi cette université de rentrée
très importante c'est pourquoi ceux qui
l'ont organisé ont beaucoup de mérite et
ceux qui viennent y participer beaucoup
de chance m6 beaucoup